hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
the arrival ok let's not waste any time
because I want to get the last of this
done in this part because after this it
really isn't that much that is hard or a
challenge I'm just making sure like none
of these hidden paths are open down
still closed um yeah well hang on no I'm
not still trying to pick up all these
little notes that I can but I've already
missed a few I know that but the main
thing is I want to get to the end of the
game and see what happens after I beat
it on hardcore hmm
yeah hardcore cuz I mean after this it's
a flashback and that wasn't exactly a
challenge because I didn't even need to
do it I just needed to get back into my
room after he forcibly got into the
house because that was a flashback
memory and not really anything and it
seems that today my computer wants to
cooperate with me and render all of this
lovely landscape although my fingers
kind of hurt guess you didn't know I
sliced my fingers up like a butcher cuts
a piece of salami I don't know something
that's gets cut its got cut while I was
opening silverware
I'm trying to keep an eye out for
anything that looks different and you
know I did wonder why this flare was
still going here but it seems like all
of these questions are destined to leave
themselves unanswered and there seems to
be some disagreement on everyone talking
in the comments like I've been trying to
avoid spoilers but from what people say
there either is or is not a secret it
either is totally different or
everything is the same so you people are
no help at all all right let's do this
hello Kate
yep okay we got the camera right up yeah
I know I know he's here
aha don't let him in but he's already in
don't you know you can't hide or run or
anything from the Slendy man he's gonna
get ya he's gonna get ya cuz he's scary
and whatnot oh no not the Slenderman Oh
Oh big whoop oh no I hope he doesn't ha
okay
I mean seriously who left all of these
open ha ha ha ha ha hey I might actually
get him yeah turn that off oh that
doesn't sound good yeah ah how did he
get in I almost had a ball that's all of
them how did he get inside I almost had
it
that's bull honky I almost had it maybe
that would have done like an easter egg
or some bull honky you like that
dramatic mistis where I I i made it so
that my character was being launched out
the window so i moved my body towards
the webcam for all you junior youtubers
out there
it's just interactivity with the
audience it really helps get you up with
the subscribers I could day like write
subscribers ok so now it's a sprint to
the finish I believe with all the fire
and whatnot
and I don't know if it's the incessant
insanity of all these horror games I've
been playing but I got this twitch in my
left eye all day and it's been really
bugging me the house had to go but the
house was right there what's going on
and there was also some disagreement as
to whether that thing in the minds was
Kate as a proxy or if that was masky no
one seems to know anything about this
game so you all are no help at all
like the least helpful people ever don't
tell Lauren about me hey wait but I'm
Lauren I'm Lauren um I'm Lorne easy okay
ah ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha okay all
the laughing maniacally some joke that I
don't get and now finally we have return
ah everything's on fire ow oh no I
walked right into the fire you gotta be
kidding me
ah I'm ROH angered earth that must have
been what happened to me the fruit whoa
what the hell what is that what I don't
even know what it was that
ha-ah
oh come on ha ha I know how I'm supposed
to see it and see this like a red smoke
pops out of nowhere but were those slend
EES nipples tentacles 10/2 nipples
nippon tickles oh come on oh I'm fine I
guess I'm okay that time it didn't kill
me all the other times yes sure kill
markiplier who cares
I hear them squiggling by oh come on Wow
there's no whatever whatever okay I'm
I'm a professional I didn't think that
the run through the woods could become
harder uh okay there's sis Lenny
tentacles mother [ __ ] okay what the
[ __ ] what the hell was going on okay
can't go that way
maybe I don't know it's changing each
time try going more right oh no oh no
can't go that way
I seriously did not think I'd be having
this much trouble with this such bull I
hear something behind me is that you
Slendy poking me in the back
mmm
seems good
what I was running full speed I couldn't
run any faster I don't even know haha ah
this is a pain in the balls what the
hell
uneven under dokey there's the tentacles
I saw Slenderman that time so I just
need to stay away from him and his long
tentacles mmm I've got climbed a tree ha
ha ha I got cut
this shit's hard yo everything's on fire
and there's his long slender tentacles
just reaching out and poking me in the
back of the neck it's quite a sensation
mmm oh not that way ok I'm going full
speed I literally cannot go any faster
what do you want from me oh I hear it oh
there it is ok I see him stay away -
stay away I'm running from you you can't
get me cuz I'm too Pro crushing markets
getting closer I gotta come on Wow
oh this is hard
why is this hard I don't even understand
what's going on
I'm just trying and it's cutting me off
at the pass
halt halt with your do with off [ __ ] all
with your to wisdom to tale you cannot
cross here you need to be this much of a
douche to walk in these woods I are
close behind me eh
oh they want to grab me a ah not again
okay uh come on there's such bull get
away get away get away
yeah no ow ow ow
all right apparently I'm gonna be here
all damn day Hodge
I'm really trying I'm not trying to fail
here I'm legitimately giving this my
best shot and apparently my best is not
good enough not for this game Oh No oh
and some fire got me really some fire
really what the hell what the hell is
going on I don't even know that's gonna
collapse to the left and it got me
he wasn't even near me
his long tentacle stick grabbed onto my
boob to me
you just I'm so angry this is ridiculous
that says wage a kill it I'm gonna go
try go way left this time because
apparently right and oh no oh no I can't
I can't go that way so I've been going
the only way that I can go maybe I just
got a wind his tentacles through the
woods in a very lazy looping fashion
I've gone up one of those ways before
and it worked I'm so angry I'm turning
French ah
catskil said ah Jess we mark Abajo
mark apply or markup er he's his French
enough for you eh now I'm going as far
left as I can go but I'm done I'm done
it was like everywhere I'm turning it's
randomly generated I know that the path
is randomly generated but everywhere I
turn the trees they fall down they fall
down and go boom like ma da da da
okay uh hi go to hell you go to hell and
you jaw
okay I see these blacks things like the
black trees are the ones that fall and
collapse so I just have to make sure I
get away from them but even if I do it
won't matter cuz plenty there and there
they're both gonna collapse what do I do
about that
Jesus
well alright then
is some [ __ ]
Oh some bulls here right here Oh quite
özil the biggest flies the [ __ ] I've
ever seen and my thought is LeBron
casting oh oh there weren't even trees
there but there are trees there how far
left are you gonna make me go seriously
seriously seriously guys this isn't
funny and they're daya Gareth Lee you're
a gotta be joking me
every pass cannot be blocked is this
bull this bull this bull
no fire okay we're doing great I'm so
happy
buddies right behind me which is great
somehow I finally have a clear goddamn
path I got my flashlight out now maybe
that'll help me there I can signal for
the fire to not be such a giant douche
fire
don't be douche allow me safe passage
nope
oh look it's all gonna be blocked again
Oh wall nope
Oh God
this game is a web of lies it's a web of
lies it's just it's it's awful it's
awful
if I can't go through here what the hell
am I supposed to do are you joking me
there are trees blocking me on every one
of them and you you're such an [ __ ]
mister ah are you kidding me
you gotta be joking me okay finally
clear I can oh no you go away
No let go of me I don't have time I
don't want to even deal with you right
now I'm I'm I have added up to hair with
you it blocked out a rocker god dammit I
didn't mean me get blocked on the rock
how do you how do you how do you not let
his tentacles get you there's got to be
some way to not have the tentacles wrap
your neck oh god damn it don't be
blocking me oh this is starting early
I'm plotting you with my lights and this
is blocked alright if I look at them did
they stop moving or what no oh you've
got to be kidding me
this isn't a challenge this I mean it's
hard no it's like impossible but this
isn't what you call a challenge this is
not a game challenge a challenge is
something that's hard but eventually you
get better at I'm upset I am I am very
upset right now and oh look my path is
blocked in hello dick what is this what
is this [ __ ] what is this [ __ ]
oh you vanished oh good that time maybe
because I was looking at your [ __ ]
and calling you out on it maybe then you
never mind where where oh no uh-uh
oh no you did it oh yeah maybe that's
what I just got to do I got to look
backwards hi
get away oh good burst of speed I like
that oh man okay block blocks got to go
right I'm really booking it maybe
finally finally the game decided it'd
not be a douche ah gosh I hope so
huh I am not letting go of the sprint
button for as long as I live cuz this is
awesome
no no no it's blocked no no ha ha no ha
ha it did it again it did where the
trees fell on each one of them I don't
know what I did before but apparently
looking at him when he's about to get
you is good I don't know whenever I hear
those tentacles get creeping up around
my neck and giblets I will turn and face
my accuser and tell him he's a douche
they're getting close but not that close
oh I wonder if someone's acting like a
son of a [ __ ] someone acting like a son
of a [ __ ] over her I hear about I hear
some son of a [ __ ] like noises going on
in my periphery it is strange how these
sounds are reminiscent of someone who is
a douche oh come on
gotta be joking to get away get the [ __ ]
off back D [ __ ] off
see what happens what am i doing
differently I almost made it up the
mountain that time except I went right
instead I left when I was I don't know I
don't know I just don't know this
doesn't make sense but I'm doing better
question mark I think maybe well those
fell that he's gonna fall to where are
you there you are okay so oh those felt
do go good okay hi how do I make you go
away
yeah flash my light at ya I don't get it
I don't get it I do not get it
I'm usually a smart guy I don't get it
again you spawn right there how about
you be a giant dick how about how about
that how about that no no there's a suck
totally counterintuitive I'm supposed to
not look at him but somehow looking at a
mix of tentacles go away I don't know hi
hi hi hi hi hi
SuperSpeed yes that's what I'm talking
about that's what I'm talking about
there we go
maybe I just needed no no no no no no
wall what was that that was new maybe I
just need to somehow get super speed
from him early on I know how to
encourage that to other than him
spawning near me and oh god everything
is on fire where is he where is he I
don't see him I hear him I don't see him
huh oh yeah hey and I'll be right with
you I said I'll be right with you Jesus
back off buddy
I have a rape whistle not afraid to use
up I'm so startled by that right I'm
startled come on go oh come on
go don't get caught on the stupid half
of a try man I'm so angry but I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna finish this video
here I'm going to beat this I don't care
how much of an [ __ ] he is I'm gonna
beat this he's such a dick though it's
just like the most [ __ ] I've ever
seen in my life
this is making me hate this game and
it's not the kind of hate where I go
like ah is so hard I'll be so relieved
once I get the skill to be to know this
is just pure unadulterated hate this is
a poor decision is he nearby where is he
I'm so startled right No
whatever Oh aah that was startling
it sounded so closed I'm walking right
into the fire aren't I
through the fire in flames yeah
that's what I'm talking about ha ha
tentacles maybe oh please let it be so
yes gotta find the key oh wait hang on
I can open these right oh that didn't
sound good
hey I was supposed to be able to open
this one why can't I open this one okay
I got to find the key right it's got to
find the key get in and out there it is
in and out picked up a key yes yes yes
whoosh yeah [ __ ] bow go down oh my flash
light went out
yes come on baby super speed
ah not gonna get me Slenderman ah
I failed you know you didn't you did not
why did you come here run run run run
about try to run Oh
all right that was bad but nothing new
there hi hi
oh yeah oh this is what I'm talking
about
wait oh come on
I went through all of that for that
little bitty thingy I went through all
of that all the hell all the flames all
the random number generation luck well
i'ma take whatever has ever made this
mark Jay Hadley of us Rob dick punting
party at blue Isle studios punch
everyone there in the dick just right as
hard as can if they're a woman just I
don't punch them in the boob or
something I heard that hurts - so just
punch I'm da
maybe there's something after the
credits I don't know let's just wait and
find out shall we
ah all right
anything in the extras no no no no okay
all right thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
Oh
you
but
Oh